[Music]
hey so i want to go break some rules and
specifically i want to go break some poi
rules but there's a few other things
that i want to do today too so come
along with me drexel here from
drexfactor poi sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and today
i'm going to talk to you a little bit
about some of the rules that we have in
poi spinning whether we recognize them
or not and some of the cool things that
can happen when we decide to
deliberately break them but before we
dive in i do just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spinballs and ultra poi for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all of
these amazing businesses and what
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that i have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to
non-business friends of the channel
johnny howard lane machinski and becca
beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission all right so
i actually have multiple missions today
see there's this awesome exhibit down at
the smithsonian called um
i want to say it's a date with eternity
or something with eternity what have you
anyway i've been seeing my friends
posting uh
photos and videos from this exhibit now
for the past couple months and i really
want to check it out myself i went and
called ahead and apparently they still
have timed entry passes for today
it's quite late in the afternoon though
so i'm going to try and
get out there as soon as i possibly can
in order to make sure that i can still
check out the exhibit today so come with
me okay so normally when i travel into
dc i go ahead and rent a bike using the
local bike share
and then just bike down the metro and
take the metro on in
that usually takes me about 30 to 40
minutes but i just checked and there's
no bikes available so
that means it's an easy 45 minutes to
get down there
not great i hope i make it in time i'm
leaving the house at roughly like
3 30 and the museum closes at 5 30 so
fingers crossed how to make it in right
and also covid cases have been spiking
like crazy here in montgomery county
where i live
so for those of you who are frustrated
with watching videos in which i'm
wearing a mask
those days of frustration are coming to
a middle all right so as i'm walking
down to the metro let me talk to you a
little bit about what i mean by rules
and why i'm interested in breaking them
goodness that there's a lot of traffic
along here i hope this doesn't mess up
the audio at all anyhow so i would
imagine that most of us as poi spinners
pride ourselves on like working within a
system where we claim that there's no
rules how that it's like whatever you
flow finds you et cetera et cetera et
cetera
and you know to a certain degree i think
that we do live by those principles but
at the same time
when it comes to the ways that we teach
beginners to spin poi there are in fact
a few rules that have become really
really prevalent in the western poi
spinning worlds for example when i first
started learning to spin poi i remember
taking those basic real turns where i
was spinning the poi and together same
and flipping from side to side to my
body
and noticing that there wasn't that huge
a difference between what my hands were
doing there versus what they were doing
in butterflies
so it stood to me to reason
that i could just change the orientation
of my planes going back and forth
between my butterflies and getting into
those reels i don't think i'm the only
beginner that had that experience but
the thing is is that usually as people
learn to spin poi we train them out of
this habit very early on
that is we try and make sure that
everything stays in this kind of wall
plane orientation
wherein
the audience can see the full profile of
your poi their planes at least
at all times this kind of harkens back
to nick woolsey's work with flowers and
kind of creating these spirograph
pictures with the poi
and of course weaves and butterflies and
everything kind of got integrated into
that
and because of that now we basically
work in a world where everything is in
wall plane and you know it turns out
that was also kind of a great fit for
video formats because
whenever we record something essentially
what the lens does is it flattens down
the picture of what it is recording
so when you're working in two dimensions
with poi it just is a great fit for
video too another element that we try
and train people out of is the instinct
to switch the orientations of our poi
planes by bending those planes you know
more often what we like to see people do
is using either pendulums or stalls to
engage what's called a zero point that
is you completely stop the momentum of
the poi and you get it working in a
completely different plane this is the
basic idea behind things like
you know plane breaks and all of the
different horizontal plane stuff that
you see me doing in my boy dance videos
so by and large when you see people that
are adhering to the style of
contemporary poi
they're trying to adhere to those two
rules more or less
and i'm kind of curious what happens
when we deliberately break them well it
is four o'clock as i'm coming up on the
metro station here everybody clap if you
believe in fairies just in time to catch
the train hallelujah
[Music]
so i'm transferring a gallery place
normally i just walk down here to the
national mall but bing is how we have a
time crunch and the
long plaza station spits me out right
next to the museum i figured that's
probably the better way to go
we are definitely coming up on rush hour
here the uh the platform is pretty
crowded
it definitely does not help that this is
one of the busiest stations along the
metro line uh i don't know if you're
gonna be able to get in
okay
is a complete mess one of the exits
appears to be closed so i'm gonna have
to find another way out of here
cool i made it out and i'm like
two blocks away so
i'm still gonna have to uh
haul it pretty quick because uh
by now i think we're at least 4 30 so
thanks
success made it to the hirschhorn now
let's see if there are still any passes
available for today
oh well
let's go play with some boys shall we
disappointing but i guess not that
terribly surprising i was getting a
pretty late start in the day but um yeah
let's let's talk about these rules that
i want to break before
so i'm sure several of you will
recognize from some of my flow videos uh
a moment that i'm very fond of taking a
four pedal anti-spin versus two pedal in
spin and doing a plane break into what's
essential a essentially a horizontal uh
buzz saw right
now while i was in the dance studio a
few weeks ago i was playing around with
this idea and suddenly changed up the
directive there where instead of just
taking that buzz saw straight across the
horizontal plane i instead did a little
bit of a plane bending thingamabob there
originally i thought i was working
towards like sticking a toroid in there
but i realized i wasn't getting the
effect that i wanted out of the toroid
and that really what i was looking for
was the thing that we're not supposed to
do
that is just like hang out in that buzz
saw and very very slowly bend the plane
from one side to the other
now here's the cool thing that happens
there um i think the eye in some
respects realizes it's seeing something
that shouldn't be happening and so this
moment builds up an awful lot of tension
in fact as i noticed myself doing this i
also noticed that getting to the other
side and finally breaking out into that
four pedal anti-spend versus two pedal
in spin felt like kind of a release of
energy and that was pretty cool so i
started playing with some other
variations on this idea among which was
the idea of taking some wall plane
anti-spins with a little linear
isolation in the middle and once again
switching into that horizontal buzzsaw
place from there i can switch into a
rapidly changing plane flipping it over
itself until i basically get back to
where i started it's a kind of visually
cool idea and likewise i found that this
was an excellent way to build up and
then release tension for example if i go
into that horizontal buzz saw and i take
my time in going around with it before i
finally break out into a anti-spin
flower again it well kind of builds up
in really cool ways
and i think that there's plenty of other
examples that are similar to this too
these are just the ones that happen to
catch my eye but let me show you those
in action first and give you a little
bit of music with them to kind of
help set a tone for how these can be
used and deployed in order to
build and release tension specifically
by breaking the rules
[Music]
oh
so this is certainly an evolving idea
but i at least wanted to share with you
some of the things that have come out of
it
i'll be sure to update you as more of
this stuff comes to mind but hopefully
this is enough at least to get you all
playing with some ideas of your own
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
sorry that i didn't show you some
awesome art in the course of it but
hopefully there was still enough here to
keep your interest
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help people find this video
this video would not be possible or not
for the kind support of all of these
nice people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
if you are not currently a supporter and
you would like to help me out on my
mission of bringing poi spinning and
flow arts to the wider world and helping
people connect with their brains and
their bodies as creative individuals you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get early access to all of my
content as well as a say what topics i
tackle in the future plus some great
extras and behind the scenes stuff as
well so go check that out please and
thank you what are your favorite tricks
that you've come up with by breaking the
rules or are you a rule breaker by
nature let me know down in the comments
i'd love to see some of the stuff that
you've come up with
in the meantime i will leave uh links to
a playlist of other videos like this
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you have to be watching on
youtube make sure to get out the flow
today and i will see you with a brand
new video very very soon uh thanks so
much for watching and have a good one
peace